امام التهديدات قررت اوروبا ما الاخ
خزانات الغاز مبكرا هذا العام واستفادت من
الغزل الروسي الموجود قبل توقفي تدفقه
الخطط نجحت لكن ماذا عن النتائج غير متوقع
يبدو ان مستويات الغاز القياسيه التي
تتسابقت الدول الاوروبيه لبلودها اعطت
وهما زائفا بحل مشكله الطاقه بروكسل
وامامه تهديداته غاز توم واقتراب الشتاء
تهافتت الصيف الماضي على شراء الغاز
وتخزينه في كل مكان تقريبا الغزو خزنا في
كهوف الملح في خزانات المياه الجوفيه
وامام الارتباك دفعت الحكومات
340 يورو لكل ميدوات في الساعه مقابل
الغاز المستورد
حققت اوروبا اهدافها بتخزين الغاز نعم لكن
هو بحلول الشتاء الطلب كان غائبا الاسعار
العاليه تلك التي عرضت على المستهلكين هي
السبب الاببرز وتاخر قدوم الشتاء عامل اخر
ايضا وامام ضعف الطلب الداخلي وامتلاء
الخزانات ترفض الدول شراء المزيد وفره
الغاز تسببت في ازمه عكسيه الشركات
الاوروبيه ترفض بيع الغازي للمستهين
باسعار السوق الحاليه امام الحكومات حلان
احلاهما مر التوجه مجددا الى الاسواق
العالميه بحثا عن الغزل رخيص وهو ما يرفع
اسعاره مجددا او فرض البيع بالخساره على
الشركات الاوروبيه
الاوقات الصعبه تغذي الخلافات المانيا رئه
الصناعه الاوربيه
في معالجته لازمه الطاقه سامحه لشركاتها
بالبحث عن مصادر الطاقه بشكل مستقل لكن
المنتجين ايضا
يتخوفون من تقلب الاسعار ويبحثون عن
العقود الطويله برلين تعمل على تقليل
الاحتماد على المحروقات حلقه مفرغه اخرى
تعمق الازمه
المانيا جاهزه لفصل الشتاء يؤكد المستشار
الالماني
لديها امتلات بنسبه 100% والتحضيرات
للشتاء المقبل بدات مع تجهيزي اول خزاننا
عائما للغاز من اصلي خمسه وعن بتكلفه
مضاعفه عن التقديرات الاوليه وفيما تسابق
المانيا الاسواقه لابقاء خزانتها ممتلئه
تزداد القوه بينها وبين الدول الاوروبيه
التي تتهممها بالمضيوم منفرده لتامين
حاجتها من الطاقه ولكن في المقابله يزداد
القلق في الداخل الالماني من العقود
الطويله لان ده التي تسعى لحكومه
الالمانيه لعقدها لشراء غازيا اسعارها
ارخص مقابل زياده الاستثماراته بالطاقه
النظيفه التي من المفترض ان يزيد الاعتماد
عليها في العقد المقبل بشكل كبير على حساب
الغاز ولكن هذا يعني بان المانيا قد تتمكن
من الخروج من العقود التي تسعى لعقدها
الان حتى ولو لم تعد بحاجه لاستهلاك الغاز
بالكميات نفسها